States are going to be making decisions very
soon about whether we are continuing the lockdown,
shut downs.
Stay at home.
Social distancing guidelines or whether things
are going to start being loosened.
Now, some states never really shut down.
Cities within those states may have taken
measures, but there are states that never
did anything.
So I'm not really talking about them.
But as an example, here in Massachusetts,
officially, we are closed until May 4th, which
is next Monday.
Charlie Baker, the Republican governor who's
been doing a pretty OK job handling things,
said that sometime this week he will have
guidance about what is coming next.
And there's speculation in a lot of states
about are we going until May 15th?
Some states already have.
Are we going until May 30?
First, a couple of states already have at
least some degree.
What is the next step?
And I think that as we think about this next
phase, we need to be very real about one element
of this, which I think informs what needs
to be done.
And it's recognizing that there are many Americans
that are not going to tolerate much more of
what I would call a full shutdown with as
many business closures as we have, as much
social distancing as we have.
And to the degree that we've had it in some
states really for a month and a half or closing
in on two months at this point in time.
But I want to be really clear as I talk about
this, I'm not saying open it up and let it
rip the way protesters want.
I'm not saying any of that.
And I'm not saying that we shouldn't be doing
what we are doing.
What
I'm saying is I think that it would be useful
to find small ways of at least making it feel
like we're taking steps in order to ensure
more people actually adhere to the most important
elements of these guidelines.
So the point of the segment is I want to be
truthful, which is tens of millions of Americans
are more or less at their limit or close to
it, either psychologically or economically.
And I believe that we are getting closer to
the end of governors being able to say everything
stays closed before people start ignoring
more and more of these guidelines.
So the basis of this commentary is essentially
harm reduction.
Some states are extended through May 15.
There are other states that are formally shut
down until the end of this month and then
may or may not open.
And I think there's kind of an
invisible wall, an imaginary wall sometime
between May 15 and June 1, specially with
the weather getting nicer in many parts of
the country, where if a governor comes out
and says we're shut down until June 15, we're
shut down under July 1.
I think it may backfire and that there will
be people who start to completely ignore it.
So here's my idea, my recommendation.
Governors could consider instead of saying
we're just going to extend the full, full
shutdown until June 1 or we're going to extend
a full shutdown until June 15 or even July
1, which will cause a lot of frustration for
many people.
I would had advised governors to instead say,
I hear the frustration.
People are psychologically and economically
exhausted from this.
So let me help you.
And the point here is we want to prevent reactions
of another month.
Screw it.
I'll do whatever I want and instead create
a reaction of, hey, here's another month during
which here are three new things that are being
extended or opened up to me.
I can do it.
I can keep wearing the mask.
I can get, you know, all that stuff.
So the idea is let's go really hard until
call it May 15th as an example, if you help
me.
Governors could say and stay inside as much
as possible.
Use masks when you're out.
Always stay six feet apart from people at
grocery stores if you do all that stuff on
May 15th.
Here are the three things I think we will
be able to do.
The three things don't have to be huge, but
they should be something because the problem
of doing March 15th to 30 first and then being
told now it's all of April and then
being told it's now all of May is it doesn't
feel like anything is happening.
And people are growing increasingly frustrated.
Even people who understand that we have to
be doing this and there are reasons for why
we are doing it.
So I don't have the exact answers.
I don't think Jim's should be open.
Trump included Jim's on phase one of his reopening
plan.
I don't think that makes any sense.
I think that's a bad idea.
Could you say with the weather getting nicer
places that have outdoor seating, you can
essentially let people have their take out
at the outdoor seating?
No waiter service.
You've got to reduce the density of the seating.
So, you know, maybe tables are 10 feet apart.
Would that be something with that?
That would be thousands, maybe tens of thousands
of restaurants where people who have been
just getting takeout
and taking it can bring the takeout to an
outdoor table, sit there and have it.
No waiter or waitress service.
Would that psychologically help?
Maybe provide a little bit of a boost to restaurants.
Maybe, I don't know.
Could you say movie theaters with masks mandatory?
Could open at 10 percent capacity, which means,
you know, there's plenty of room for people
to be very far apart.
Social distancing in line to buy tickets and
no concession stands.
I don't know.
Would people even go?
Would people want that?
I'm not really sure.
I'm thinking out loud here for the social
distancing component between friends and family.
Could they say outdoor gatherings in your
backyard or in the park or whatever with masks
among people not in high risk groups who have
had no symptoms and continue to have no symptoms
as long as you stay six feet apart?
Would that feel like a win, given how things
have been for four, six, seven, close to eight
weeks?
At this point in time, I don't know.
I'm thinking out loud here.
But my point is, if is on April 30th, say
we're now extending till May thirty first.
I believe the frustration will push a lot
of people to abandon all the guidelines and
that would be really bad.
Instead, if we can feel like there's progress.
Imagine the governor says we made it to April
30th.
Thank you.
New cases are down, but they're still too
high to reopen.
I have determined we are going not to phase
one, but to phase zero point one.
And here are three things that I am saying
we can do carefully from May 1st to the 15th.
I'll check back in with you in 15 days and
see if we can do anything else.
The feeling that things are improving could
actually get people, people to more closely
abide by masks, work from home.
All that stuff.
And then we we may be better off overall than
creating frustration and abandonment of the
guidelines.
Thinking out loud.
Let me know
what
you think.